Next you will see how to perform various
mathematical operations on np arrays.
Let's use a random heading of integers.
Let's create an array with shape
five rows and four columns.
Let's see the output.
So here's an array with five rows,
four columns, and
all the values between the range 0 and
10.
Note how we used seed, the random
number generator with the constant,
to get the same sequence
of numbers every time.
Let's run again and
see if the output remains the same.
You can see that we have
the same values for the array.
Summing all the elements in an array
is as simple as calling the function
sum on the array.
Here is our array a, and
we call the sum function on it.
Let's check the output.
This is our array and
this is sum of all the elements present
in the array, which comes out to be 79.
We can also sum in a specific
direction of the array.
What I mean by direction
is along rows or columns.
NumPy gives this
direction a special name.
It is called access.
Access is equal to zero,
signifies rows, and
access is equal to one
indicates columns.
Remember this terminology as
you will use it frequently.
Let's code to make things clear.
Passing the parameter, axis,
along with a specific value will
give you the sum along that axis.
To understand this,
let's first see the output.
To get the sum of each column, we pass
the value to the axis attribute as zero.
And to get the sum of the rows,
we pass the value as one.
To understand this imagine if you wanted
to sum the values of each column,
what would you iterate on?
You would say something like,
For each column, sum all the values
of each row of that column.
So you would essentially
iterate over the rows.
Hence we pass axis=0 to compute column
sums and similarly axis=1 for row sums.
Observe the output when we pass axis=0,
we get four values.
These are basically
the sum of each columns.
And when we passed axis=1.
We get five values which
are the sum of each row.
Let's go ahead and try some basic
operation like finding minimum,
maximum, and mean of an array.
So, if I want minimum along columns,
I have to go through each row
of each column, so axis equal to zero
to get the minimum of each column.
To get the maximum of each row,
similarly we call a max function and
pass access equal to one.
Just calling a.mean,
that is array dot mean, will give
us the mean of the entire array.
Of course we can get mean along each
axis as we did for max and min.
Observe the output.
Minimum of the first column is one,
which is shown over here.
This value is essentially,
minimum of the first column.
This is of second, this is of third,
and this is of fourth.
Similarly, for maximum of the each row,
you can observe that for
the first row, the maximum is five,
and it is shown here.
The mean of all
the elements is 3.95 which
is calculated using the mean function.
There are many more functions
which you can experiment with.
Check the documentation link
in the instructor's notes.